now it's worth pointing out that this
magical program texture Packer provides
a nice little output option that you can
see right here called trim what this
option will do is that for each image it
will find out the true boundaries for it
so let's say an artist gives you a
texture but only puts pixels in the
center part of it
the needed pixels of this image only
occupy a sub portion of the physical
space that's been provided as such we
get a lot of wasted pixels texture
Packer provides this trim option that
will go through and remove unneeded and
unused pixels mostly transparent from
all the sprites that are given to an
atlas the results are actually pretty
significant you can see that the size of
the Atlas that contains the blank unused
pixels is significantly larger than the
one that trims properly now it's worth
pointing out however that when you use
this option the format of the data in
your output JSON from texture Packer is
going to change a little bit so
previously the frame parameters width
and height values matched the same as
the sort size so if your input image was
128 by 128 the size in your texture
atlas was going to be 128 128 and of
course the trimmed value is false once
you start with trimmed equal to true
you'll notice that the frame width and
height represents the true boundaries of
the used pixels in the input texture it
no longer matches the size of the input
texture exactly